bugatti has done the near impossible
with its near sharone this 2.6 million
dollar beast is the successor to the
Veyron and it debuted in Geneva Monday
night this is the 1500 horsepower
w16 supercar that Bugatti says will go
to 60 miles per hour and well under two
and a half seconds
it has 1600 Newton meters of torque with
a two-stage turbo engine and a top speed
of 311 miles per hour or more it's
faster and more powerful than the Veyron
with a totally new stiffer suspension a
new aerodynamic system bigger brakes
bigger wheels and if you can believe it
improved handling and on-road dynamics
but the best part of this new beast is
how bugatti has managed to make it
beautiful - the swooped air vents on the
side the carbon-fiber rear in the square
LED lights on the low front face look
extreme but well finished like an animal
that has learned to combine its sheer
power with the precision of control
you got to make only 500 of them and a
full one-third of those have already
been spoken for
it's rare when the literal best in the
world of luxury design and performance
converge into one object let alone a car
if you see one in the wild count
yourself lucky